Ibrahim raisy was welcomed to Beijing
with a grand ceremony at the Great Hall
of the people it's the Iranian
President's first visit to China and his
second meeting with Chinese leader Xi
Jinping since September she says Iran is
an old friend of China both sides are
working to deepen ties in the face of
growing tensions with the United States
although Beijing denies this is the
reason for the visit
cooperation between China and Iran does
not Target any Fair country
on Tuesday raisi also met with Chinese
Premier Lika Chiang and the head of the
national people's Congress Lee Jan shu
Jules were signed to extend Corporation
in trade Agriculture and infrastructure
plans made under a 25-year strategic
agreement signed in 2021.
China is Iran's biggest trading partner
and the only customer of its heavily
sanctioned oil exports in the last 12
months Iran has exported more than 14
billion dollars to China an increase of
58 from the previous year and we have
imported more than 13 billion dollars
from China
U.S led sanctions have left Iran in its
toughest economic situation in more than
40 years Beijing has condemned the
sanctions and Washington's withdrawal
from a 2015 nuclear deal with Iran and
several world powers
she didn't think says China will
continue to take part in negotiations to
get the agreement reinstated
Abraham British visit comes as both
China and Iran strengthen their
relationships with Russia both sides say
they're opposed to a world order led by
the United States and its allies Beijing
will be looking to Tehran for
reassurances of its continued support on
the global stage including on issues
such as the status of Taiwan and the
South China Sea